et maintenant est ce que gary est encore
là en train de regarder la scène ont vu
direct on ne le sait pas mais on devrait
bientôt le découvrir
ouais sur le ralenti superbe superbes
plans d'un joueur
tempête sous un crâne on n'avait pas le
titre de cette auto ouais tempête sous
un crâne et tempête sous un crâne seul
est-ce qu'on peut avoir un plein sur le
fauteuil de kasparov faut voir s'il y
est pas derrière ça ça devrait être
c'est possible n'ont ils pas n'a rien ay
fauteuil et ont apparemment on a le
fauteuil médiévale de kasparov cram
nicolas la chronique ça fait un beau
plan indique très concentré oui les yeux
qui bouge alors sur internet on les voit
probablement pas mes chroniques qui est
à l'affût d'une solution un calcul très
vite ses joueurs je crois qu'ils
calculent vraiment très vite à eux ils
calculent extrêmement vite
donc ils peuvent concentrer leur
attention non pas sur le calcul mais
justement sur les considérations
générales positionnelle qui sont les
plus importantes et donc il ne lui sont
pas distraits par les variantes annexes
ouais tout à fait ils sont bien bien
concentré cram nique en plein écran
kasparov n'est pas la cram nick
réfléchit encore à la la ça tourne bien
il est stabilisé cornic très concentré
la vue hélicoptère comme on a baptisé
cette caméra est placée en hauteur donc
des très belles images et des vraiment
d'être belle image quoi tout simplement
alors on va revenir peut-être aller à
l'échec et des mots de démonstration
voilà voilà voilà voilà nous nous y
voilà donc toujours cette variante on va
rappeler le début des coûts de cette
variante c'est assez important c'est le
couffo aussi ce que craint munich peut
jouer l'idée de ce coup joué très vite
3b 7 pendant que le fou n'est plus en 17
c en est plus attaquées par la tour pour
ensuite jouer autour des mythes ou alors
tour vite
enfin bref passer la tour oui sur ça
garry kasparov tenterait f2f 4 menaçant
la fourchette travnik j'aurais cavaliers
h4 défendons l'idée revenir en f 5 puis
éventuellement trois idées très c'est
surtout on peut empêcher le pion aux
nefs d'avancé empêcher le pire m
d'avancé et sur quelle g3 pour persister
on jouerait cavadee f5 et maintenant
après l'échangé éventuel qu'avait dit
franck cavallier fou prend est bien ici
je crois que c'est clair
les noirs sont mieux 900 mieux les noirs
sont mieux parce que la menace est fou
c'est 2 le cahier peut pas bouger mais
qui est des trois peut pas vraiment
bougé les noirs vous sortir toutes leurs
pièces et en finale quand même la paire
de fou va finir par parler rappelons que
quand il ya des pions des deux côtés les
fous ont tendance à être plus fort que
les cavaliers et donc dans les positions
ouvertes et quand les pions sans bloquer
si les pions sont bloqués sur deux
couleurs différentes c'est à dire des
cases blanches à gauche des cases noires
à droite
la paire de fous sera plus forte que fou
et cavaliers donc qu'il est pas foutu
kramnik chronique n'est pas foutu dans
cette position là non mais de toute
façon on sait bien que chronique n'est
pas foutu position et légères avantage
blanc ça c'est probable nous revenons
nous revenons après fou aussi c'est la
possibilité pour détenir
nick qui voudraient dans cette position
sortir ces pièces très chaud très chaud
alors c'est pas la position réelle
évidemment c'est faux six possibilités
garry kasparov peut également ne pas se
laisser distraire et jouets qui essaient
3 pour aller sur la caisse des cinq ça
c'est possible aussi mme way c'est
possible sur quoi on envisage bien
entendu roi 17 avec une position tout à
fait tranquille je dirais pour l'admirer
chronique dans cette position lit 17 rue
autour des 8
tout simplement on a du fleuve 5 aussi
dans l'air qui traîne non il ya beaucoup
de ça à l'air d'être ça a l'air d'être
tranquille ça valait le coup à 5 c koi 5
avait faibli le pian b3 et normal on va
revenir encore sur la position qui est
telle qu'elle était il ya quelques coups
ici kremnica jouer à 5
j'espère faire la tour du para 4 et
maintenant ça permet justement dans
certaines variantes donc à très très
long terme c'est une vision à très long
terme d'attaqué le plan b 3 avec le fou
de cases blanches avec le foot casse
blanche que kasparov n'a plus donc
évidemment dans cette pression cramique
envisage le couffo 6 c'est malin ni dans
la trame nicklas et les malins il est
très fier d'y aboli qu elle aille
réfléchit alors il faudrait voir le
temps parce qu'ils aient l'impression
qu'ils rattrapent les parents invités de
grand baie j'ai pas si on peut si on
peut avoir le temps exact de la pendule
ouais pas mal dont 37 minutes à kasparov
cinquante-et-une pour kramnik on est au
18e coup non pardon 17e coup maintenant
18e beaucoup pour les blancs pardon et
c'est au nord de jouer demain sa 18e
coupe pour les blancs et roddick en
pleine réflexion
vous noterez que là de temps en temps
les joueurs jeu d'un petit coup d'oeil à
la pendule pour contrôler le temps qui
s'écoule
effectivement effectivement nous avons
jeté un petit coup d'oeil à cette
pendule alors la magie du direct
stéphane laborde est appelée à sortir
il sort donc alors là j'ai deux micros
mais je ne vais en pause et un ac as
part of là il est là il
ils surveillent un peu tout ce qui se
passe ils surveillent vladimir kramnik
ouais ouais non mais c'est chaud mais on
attend quand même le coup de crâne nique
c'est bizarre qui joue qui réfléchissent
dans cette position et devrait jouer
fois aussi il devrait vraiment le faire
parce que là on ne sait pas trop ce
qu'il attend sa pendule tourne
et alors en fait le plus surprenant dans
cette position ces cas parfois aussi si
on n'arrive pas à trouver de coûts
logique pour les noirs ah ouh là là là
il a joué le coup h 5h 4h 5h 4 alors
bonne idée donc voilà vous êtes sur
l'échiquier actuellement des los boys
nous allons bientôt passer sur
l'échiquier de démonstration dès que ça
sera prêt c'est un coup voilà nous
pouvons nous y sommes h4h 4 pas mal
l'idée fixe et les pions blancs ça c'est
l'idée c'est clair maintenant le pion g2
n'avancera plus au g4 à cause de la
fameuse règle de la prise en passant
c'est à dire que si le pion blanc avance
de deux cases angers 4 le pion h prend
le plonger en passant voilà c'est une
règle du jeu d'échecs en passant à côté
quand le pion vient d'avancer de deux
cas sont peu le ramasser en passant ce
mettant donc sur la case entre la caisse
de et par la caisse d'arrivée du plan
blanc c'est une règle on a droit de le
faire donc ici j'ai dejé câble devient
mauvais devient tout simplement mauvais
donc g nick fixe les pions blancs
gaskarov peut toujours jouer sont
planqués et c3 qui est des cinq c'est
sûr il peut aussi jouer f4 mais
maintenant f4 perd de son intérêt
parce qu'en plus kramnik avec son
courage 4control la casse g3 est donc
peut jouer fouet f5 avec sérénité
alors attention puisque voilà le retour
le retour je crois de notre commentateur
choc qui va revenir
et bien non il n'est pas là
n'est pas encore là m il va nous revenir
bientôt donc ici voilà des c'est très
intéressant ce que je veux quand tu dis
qu'il a joués h 4 et s'affronteront la
cage et fort sa menace donc de jouer
pour f5 et c'est parfaitement en
harmonie ce qui est en train de se
passer il a joué à cinq pour provoquer à
4 et a fait bien au cube et 3 maintenant
ils jouent aux cartes pour jouer au f5
sans pouvoir être chassé il stoppe la
majorité de kasparov
ils menacent de venir à ta question des
trois est une fois de plus c'est la
fameuse magie de ces grands champions
à chaque fois qu'il en a un qui joue un
coup on pense qu'il a pris davantage ici
indiscutablement on a envie de dire que
cramique se retrouvent mieux dans cette
position puisqu'il a réussi à
neutraliser les coups de 14 mai kasparov
et prêt à jouer là il va jouer
ça y est c'est fait il a joué cavalier
en c3 retour de stéphane laborde
alors bonjour stéphane stéphane c'était
bien de revient stéphane est là et garry
kasparov ne s'est pas laissé distraire
par mais dernière chronique dans cette
position il a mis le cavalier sur la
casse ces trois voilà ils les joueurs
sont partis une fois de plus oui oui
c'est décidément les aura pas souvent en
même temps sur la sur la scène
non alors c'est rare il faut profiter
des plans où les deux joueurs sont là
une chaise vide contre une autre chaise
vide
et oui c'est un jeu de chaise la voilà
nous y sommes complètement
on verra ça assez longtemps fait sage ou
de chaises musicales puisque ya une
prime aux joueurs qui terminent le
premier sur sa chaise
voila voila tout à fait tout à fait en
fait le but du jeu est d'être le moins
ainsi possible ça a été les bookmakers
ont pris des paris là dessus puisque on
sait qu en angleterre il ya énormément
de paris qui ceux qui se font et se
défont alors chronique est revenu cavani
c3 a été joué par gary kasparov
apparemment garry kasparov a les idées
claires
renault c'est à dire qui sait ce qu'il
veut ouais il le fait vite oui donc
laïque valais sur les causes des saints
qui a aucun doute là dessus et je veux
faire cette case finale en peut-être
pendant que tu étais absent tu as raté
quelque chose
granic qui a joué le coup h4 oui très
important de travailler s'ils regardent
mais de mettre le fond f5 sentier qui
avait g3 donc le camion eu d'autres
kasparov ne servait plus à rien
puisqu'il ne peut plus venir là donc ils
amiens ses trois entrées donc damien c3
et autres avantages c'est à dire que le
full avenir en f1 qui maintenant c'est
probable et il y aura plus de gedo g4
non plus à présent les prises en passant
well j'ai expliquées en détail
bravo donc là c'est joli coup de blocage
de kramnik trahi mais il est vraiment
malin ni mal il est phénoménal qui joue
sur les ailes krainik années joissains
qui déjoue h4 mais c'est dire qu'en fait
il dit à kasparov vient me chercher un
petit peu ouais mais c'est une fois de
plus que j'expliquais c'est que une fois
de chroniques ajout acheter un casque a
très bien on se dit que les noirs sont
peut-être mieux
oui c'est la caf à chaque fois que je
joue et rejoue c'est lui qui est mieux
voilà c'est ça en fait le champion joue
et gagne j'ai pu le dire ça comme ça
puisque à voile à 34,47 ça devient chaud
alors ce qui est bien ouais c'est quand
même le line up qui approchent passé là
là ça va être intéressant parce qu'il ya
19 coups il leur reste donc 34 minutes
kasparov 47 minutes à kramnik le tout
pour jouer on secoue s'adonne donc
un rythme qui va être assez soutenue
soutenue et voir même qu on pourrait
analyser à peu près la moyenne il reste
21 coups à jouer en 34 minutes et
espérons-le de jouer ses coûts en une
minute trente et kramnik dojo ses coûts
en deux minutes
c'était en dessous de la moyenne de
départ qui est de 30 minutes parcours
ouais tout à fait donc là ça va
s'accélérer
ça va s'accélérer on a passé le on a
passé le cap difficile aux magnans
lequel difficile le cap blanc le capelan
ou plutôt ça long le capelan long le cap
long des coques appelons le cap selon le
célèbre joueur
kaplan alors qu'ils essaient 3 vient
d'être jouée gc 3 bien des jours on va
passer sur l'échiquier démonstration
voilà krainik hésite entre m sont fous
en f 5 ou sont fous ans et 6
de toute façon ici dans cette position
on attend vraiment un coup de foudre
cram midi probablement en dessous des 7
puisque m le fond au set ça a pas l'air
génial non dans la mesure où quand le
cavalier viendra sur la case des 5
il va l'attaquer centre il attaquera le
feu et en plus le fonds en fuite est pas
si mal placé puisqu'il bouazizi en geste
est quasiment prêt développés alors
maintenant qu'il est noir enjoué h4
peut-être la torah schmidt va venir sur
la case h5 c'est possible ça c'est
possible c'est ce qu'on appelle une tour
nouveau lot ni comment tu dis niveau
l'oni niveau l'oni donc si célèbre
maître italien
voilà et finalement une fois que la
torgnole le faut et fuite est pas si mal
puisque ils contrôlent g7 qui attaque et
pas le coupé 2 2 par transparence
il contrôle des cases à tour sera bien
placé puisque elle attaquera le pion aux
symboles à la tour sera bien passer à la
trappe toros elle pourra venir aussi sur
la casse g5 restera le problème de la
torah 8 qu'il a décidément ne joue pas
c'est vraiment le problème ni noir voilà
tout va vite ça va être résolu très
facilement on va jouer roi bessette fou
aussi ce bon cheval arabe et c'est tout
de suite c'est pour tous habillés loi
parce que si on ne peut pas la variable
tout simplement on l'a déjà mentionné
ont bien attaqué français 5 effet voilà
sirois bessette il ya cavaliers prince
tuant ses cinq échecs fou prend
cavaliers et tout reprend fou 17 lens
qui est très important quand même il ya
une évolution radicale dans la position
c'est qu'avant on se disait bombe à
toute façon personne n'a rien à faire
c'est à dire les joueurs prennent leur
temps on commença par lé mot nage ou
prophylactiques et ainsi de suite
maintenant si on donne cinq coups à
krainik on sait exactement ce qu'il va
faire il va jouer fois aussi soufflé 5
roy bessette tour des huit tours à
saint-ours g5 salaire alors ça va vite
je vous ai fait une succession de coups
mais tous les coups sont représentés en
fait si anvers et on voit très
clairement le plan de crem dit que la
seule pièce qui ne bouge pas c'est le
fouet et suite qui est en rouge oui il
est bien placé il a prêté il ya
plusieurs cases il n'y a pas de
meilleure classe parce que s'ils jouent
influence en 7,6 vendre cet hiver un
petit peu en porte-à-faux
oui mais sous le pied devient donc il
est en effet utile de bien placer mon
savoir lequel j'ai six fait pression sur
cinq
oui bon on retrouve un jeu virtuel où
elle a trouvé ses pas il s'est pas
énervé krainik là il s'est pas énervé
tranquillement 26 cra munich est cramé
plutôt bien c'est à dire que maintenant
donc comme on l'a dit cyclonique jeu
cinq coups de suite il va obtenir une
belle position et on ne peut pas en dire
autant pour kasparov
alors il maintenant que h4 est faux
aussi sont là ça y est il faut aussi
bien joué et vladimir ouais bien joué
bien jouer tu vas l'avoir tu vas l'avoir
tient non mais bon les commentaires ne
sont pas engagés du tout tranquille on
aimerait surtout une belle partie un
atome on a surtout ne veulent pas un
seul vainqueur
le jeu d'échecs voilà c'est la devise de
diagonale donc faut aussi kasparov ça y
est ça y est il fait la grise mine à la
sas et ça c'est superbe
ça c'est super bon alors là on va
revenir sur la pression parce que là il
faut absolument bien détaillé ce qui est
en train de se payer alors à noter que
kasparov
même s'il a du poil aux mains comme on
peut le voir n'a pas un poil dans la
main
humour il n'a pas un fana sacré gary
sacré stéphane est donc faux sites non
mais alors moi non mais là comme anton
cette position parce que là c'est
superbe c'est en train de se passer on a
cru très longtemps que kasparov avait
trouvé un plan d'enfer en fait donc
finalement la cramif bien de réfléchir
longtemps et de trouver un contre-plan
ce qui en fait il a contourné le plan de
kasparov
il a dit aqa scores of bad écoute ton
plan il est très bien
t'as qu'à jouer donc là kasparov peut
terminer son plan que joue et qu'il y
ait des cinq mais malheureusement dans
cramique en fait lui à jouer vraiment
dans l'esprit de la position l'esprit de
la position c'était que kasparov avance
ses deux pions f2 et g2 et crame dick
lui a joué h 5 h 4 donc la bloquer
plongé de bloquant net la majorité de
garry kasparov
donc ça c'est très important tl selon f
k le plus bref qui peut bouger mais le
problème c'est que les noirs contrôle
bien la cause des 100 c'est à dire que
si si l'option avançant la f4 web a
simplement au fouet 5il phocéen qui
bloque le pion blocage de pions donc ici
alors par contre c'est surprenant quand
même cramique aurait pu mettre le feu au
f5 directement et ne l'a pas fait alors
pourquoi je ne sais pas peut-être que
sur f4 en fait il a prévu de
joué-lès-tours h5 ça c'est possible
aussi
oui c'est ainsi qu'à sport joue le coup
et f2f 4 donc menace en la maintenant
célèbre fourchette
oui internationale qui a attaqué deux
pièces détourage scène conventionnée une
dernière fois
voilà la tour viendrait ici sur la case
à chocs donc là c'est une simulation de
variantes ce n'est pas gelé contrôlant
la case f5 très bien et peut-être même
avec l'idée de placer la tour au f5
oui où elle exercera une pression sur
kiev car ça c'est possible
donc ici kasparov à mon avis va
réfléchir puisque la après h4 non ce
n'est pas la position
la position est celle là questroy foulée
c'est trois fois aussi soit la position
épuré puis la cre ami qui veut jouer roi
bessette
lan le plan graphique on le connaît un
roi bcn tour des mythes tour à tour au
taureau huit taureaux 8 parce que tour
des huit si si ça marche on évite alors
je travaille michael et prince et 5e
chez il fou prend défend la tour ah oui
oui il faut prendre cavaliers qui défend
la tour ont donc ici travnik à un plan
canonique qui a clairement un plan
kasparov n'en a plus alors idées pour
kasparov
tu me diras stéphane ce que tu en penses
qu'elle manie de 4,8 kg 5 ouais t'as
attaque le faux 6 ça fait pression sur
f7 ça a l'air pas mal mais alors
simulons camillo 4 comme possibilité oui
kramnik j'aurais fou où tout rothstein
qu'encore une fois ou tour h 50 et tout
à fait tord hcr qui a l'air plus dans
l'idée 300 de ses plus proches cinq
contrôles la casse du siècle car il peut
pas sauter dessus
cette tour est très bien placée en moi
je 500 surprenant oui c'est vraiment une
très très bonne disposition qui a selon
ses chroniques un jour position de la f4
peut-être f4 là maintenant les fenêtres
ne menace rien mais si sam hanna
scaliger 5 ha oui bonjour infosat tout
simplement sur un site et voilà
non mes chroniques en fait à des
conceptions positionnelle qui sont
proprement incroyable pour incroyable
c'est un vraiment un nouveau c'est un
nouveau karpov c'est un nouveau joueur
très positionnelle qui peut laisser
venir l'adversaire jusqu'à la limite
mais le stopper à ce moment là parce que
là on a vu qu'à sport gros avantage de
développement meilleure structure de
pions eu l'initiative est chronique avec
gros sang froid a réussi à retomber dans
la position qu'on va on va y revenir à
cette position
la pression actuelle c'est celle là et
ici il a tout donné à kasparov kasparov
a fait tout ce qu'ils voulaient faire
sauf une chose
il lui a bloqué sa majorité pions et
maintenant on ne voit plus d'idées pour
garry kasparov alors cependant
l'évaluation de l'opposition les noirs
ne sont pas mieux c'est une chose qu'il
faut dire on se laisse emballé par le
dernier coup non mais il ya dix ans
l'air de bien contenir l'adversaire oui
mais nommée terrain ce qu'ils peuvent
progresser on peut arriver une provision
de blocus ça peut arriver aussi de
blocus de blocus avec lenny les blancs
les noirs ne peuvent progresser
tout à fait c'est possible
donc une sorte de blocus je crois qu'il
y fait non il faut c'est possible c'est
possible que personne ne puisse
progresser mais ça arrive rarement
c'est vraiment quand il reste autant de
pièces que ça par exemple un blocus
typique ce serait avoir contre roy mais
personne ne peut plus progresser mais là
on en est quand même assez loin
suffisamment d'options être pièce est
forte car en fait il n'y a pas beaucoup
de pièces échangées il ya quoi un pion
n'dam est un fou un fou contre un
cavalier donc c'est une finale qu'on
peut qualifier de complexe c'est une
finale c'est à moitié entre la finale en
milieu de jeu quoi c'est pas clair oui
mais c'est pas clair mais là on a
presque est-ce que cramique peut pas
aussi a essayé d'activer son roi en
l'emmenant bessette en c6 parce qu'il a
l'air ouais on peut amener loin ses six
mais ça n'a pas vraiment l'intérêt
majeur n'a pas intérêt majeur puisque le
roi il ya quand même beaucoup de pièces
encore pour qu'on ait envie d'amener le
roi centre le roi est une place forte en
finale mais quand ils risquent pas de se
faire mater là quand il reste deux tours
de canadiens fou côté blanc c'est un peu
dangereux d'avenir envers le centre donc
une règle c'est que le roi dont on doit
essayer de le mettre à l'abri tant qu'il
ya encore beaucoup de pièces sur
l'échiquier tout à fait peut-être un
bilan pendule pour voir dans quel état
et garry kasparov malien pendule ou et
voilà on m'a fait un petit bilan pendule
aaa il a réfléchi la paire comptant 29
minutes pour jouer 21 coups donc il va
passer sous la barre des 1 min park ou
s'il continue à réfléchir et une époque
où on peut commencer à dire que c'est
une crise d'autant ouais c'est une crise
de temps et il a l'air de faire la moue
et on l'a vu faire la moue il n'est pas
il est pas content il n'est pas content
il n'est pas content mais pas content
mais cependant il est plein de
ressources
ah oui il a effectivement à la lie à
imola la carrie diaries ne sait plus
trop quoi faire là il est en train de se
faire barrage au candidat il n'est pas
content
oh là là là là là c'est regarder dans
les yeux et en bulgarie la houlala ne
veut plus voir sa position à une revient
à krainik revient que va faire cramer
sera le petit au diable quand même à
garry kasparov
il est pas content là il fait sa mine
des mauvais jours là ah ouais halal à
l'acteur se kasparov tient l acteur a
chassé pas un acteur justin l'acteur
simule alors que la passion qui simule
pas trop un acteur simule on s'en
rappellera iiie reich espère of ne
simule pas il est là il a alerté quand
il est quand même ils allaient embêtés
hein c'est clair à l'amitié vaut mieux
regarder lui pour savoir samedi qu'il
est très détendue peut-être un plan
général avec les deux joueurs wii pour
voir un peu 6 regarde si ça ça c'est
typique des parties de kasparov
caspar ont fait pencher sur l'échiquier
vers l'avant il met la pression générale
adversaire est plutôt surtout kramix
autocratique qui est très cool qui
aiment karpov c'était pareil karpov
avait peur physiquement web a aucun prof
terre car pour ce n'était pas non plus
très grand alors que véronique 8 il est
bon on peut pas dire qu'il a peur
chronique mesure quand même presque
domaine oui donc même si la leur petit
en vidéo sur votre écran il est en fait
très très lent et kasparov n'est pas
content il sait pas trop bon alors
peut-être
il a regardé ça fait deux parties alors
ça c'est typique de regrets tant
généralement non non non je pense qu'il
veut savoir à quel coût on en est avancé
il regarde plutôt vers le futur il
regarde sa pendule je regarde le nombre
de coups en année ils voient 19e coup
une seconde posturale et sa partie pour
se dire at-elle coup qu'est ce que j'ai
fait j'ai pas fait une gaffe ça c'est
vrai que c'est dans le stylo kasparov
normalement c'est pas une bonne attitude
ouais puisqu'on n'a pas venir regretter
ce qu'on a fait c'est dans les torts
c'est fait ouais mais c'est vrai que
c'est bien dans le style que kasparov
veut se donner c'est à dire le joueur
expressif
on n'est plus temps j'ai raté ça je
regarde ma femme je suis énervé
en fait je pense que d'un point de vue
pratique il regarde plutôt sa feuille
pour savoir à combien coup il a joué sur
scène pourtant on va rappeler la règle
c'est très simple mais voilà rappeler la
pendule
il reste commune 28 27 minutes à casper
27002 kasparov pour atteindre le 40e
coup et dans ses minutes il va voilà 26
minutes pour atteindre le 40e coup ils
ont joué 19 19 coups ce qui veut dire
que lille brest 26 minutes pour jouer 21
coup ci il dépasse ses 26 minutes en
ayant joué que dix villes jouent il a
perdu jouer jo qu'avaient les dessins
les cinq menacerait menace rien donc
chronique à peut-être qu'il veut jouer
cavalier f4 la bulgarie on a retrouvé
une idée l'om pouvait déjà le joué
d'avancé
alors qui est des cinq revoyons web on a
dit que ça faisait pas peur qu'avec 4
puisqu'on avait dit que c'est vrai il y
aura un échange du cahier g6 qui n'était
pas forcément une mauvaise chose et le
fujian riffs 5 tout à fait tout à fait
donc 4 4 c'est pas vraiment une menace
et surtout tarifs 5 le fou menace fous
ces deux alors bon on va montrer lavande
qu'on a dit c'est à dire que si krainik
joue par exemple trois baies -celles
anodin qui met la tour habitants jeu
c'est un bon coup kaspars daugavins
10h04 on échange
il a joué et joue aux grammy croît de 7
il devient de jouer à voir bien jouer la
baisse est d'accord donc ça c'est très
bien puisqu'on est en train de le
regarder ses cavalières capela la
possibilité pendant quatorze fosses 5
maintenant aux menaces poussé deux avec
ce qu'on appelle un ramassage scolaire
ramassage scolaire parce que le biome b3
et le pian c4 ou le client 4 vont être
perdus tous les pions sont faibles à
lhassa joue vite là ça joue vite
arnica jouer tempo roi bessette il
rivalisera 23 alors joly hm il veut
jouer f4 f5 garé il veut jouer f4 f5 il
n'en démord pas il est revenu sur la
case de troie parce qu'ils contrôlent la
case f5
qu'est-ce qu'il a échoué c'est qu'avec
sempra bléka valises qu'ils ont joués f4
f5 voient la main des doctrines kasparov
alors est-ce qu'on peut montrer chic et
démonstrations voilà la f4 f5 pourquoi
parce que lecavalier e3 maintenant le
cavaly revenus de la case des cinq ans
le 3 le caillou 3 contrôle parfaitement
cette case donc maintenant on peut
menacer f4 f5 difficile pour les noirs
d'empêcher
puis ce difficile pour le nom de
l'empêcher mais tout à fait qui est
possible un peu joué encore cavaliers
aux 7 pour empêcher mais ça libérerait
la case et leucate alors il faut le
jouer au bon moment non probablement ici
vadimir kramnik envisage de toute façon
de jouer tourage cinq mois je pense que
ça c'est une très bonne possibilité pour
chroniques tour h5 attaque le pion aux
cinq attaques le pion on n'attaque pas
le but en 5 puisqu'il est défendu deux
fois et par le four b2 et par le biais
des trois un peu juif 4 quand même mais
après avec 4,4 on joue simplement
claudio date qu'a lieu cette et ensuite
cavalier 5 où on peut jouer g6 après
c'est vrai on peut jouer autour des 8
aussi ouais ouais ça devient un autour
des 8 c'est pas possible à tour des buts
n'est plus possible
alors justement on va le fond on
mentionne truc n'est plus possible
puisque le cas et détroit vient prendre
l'option c5 avec échec et la tour d vite
se retrouvant prise par la tour d un
voilà ça fera un gagnant plus d'une tour
revoyons la position actuelle que les
joueurs sur l'échiquier
il vient de jouer qui a eu lieu trois
garry kasparov il me veut jouer f2f 4
suivi des f4 f5
quelles sont les possibilités diverses
de vladimir kramnik et peut jouer tour
h5 et cavaliers obsède c'est ce qu'on
vient de voir s'il joue cavalier hausse
est tout de suite les cavaliers h4 qui
me pose problème et donc à part tour h5
on ne voit pas de coût pour vladimir
kramnik je pense qu'on peut résumer ça
comme ça si tour des huit une tour des
huit y arrive de f4 ouais mais fdf
quatre cavaliers au cet homme et cette
f4 f5 et non à calais prend ses cinq
échecs ou si ça marche pas il ya
beaucoup de choses il ya beaucoup de
choses ouais donc là à part tour h5 on
ne voit pas de coût pour vladimir
kramnik cependant tour h5 a l'air de
tenir
donc pour l'instant évaluation de la
position cramique devrait jouer courage
5 et tenir qui est mieux aider c'est
toujours pareil ça ne bouge pas c'est
équilibré c'est équilibré
donc ne nous emballons pas mais à la
taille les grains qui l'a fait tournoyer
voyez mériterait force g nique il l'a
jouée il ya très fort il a joué le coup
qu'on avait prévu il a joué coupé
revenant c'est quand même une garantie
de sécurité et pour vous qui écoute et
des commentaires et pour nous qui qui
sommes ses comptes en ont finalement
assez satisfaits de trouver des coûts du
numéro deux mondial après à l'amour mais
regardez kasparov la famille qui parti
l'entourage 5 trop facile le temps il
faut vendre le temps cet ouvrage semble
trop facile à contrôler kasparov
il faut absolument voir l'otan c'est
important ça devient critique
ça devient hautement critique ont
dépensé beaucoup de temps d'être cinq
minutes pour kasparov
quarante et une minutes pour kramnik
donc la chronique maintient à distance
au niveau du temps c'est important et
loi de dominer l'adversaire au niveau du
temps ça veut dire qu'on a une
initiative aussi est venu autant c'est
c'est tout et rien à la fois puisque 25
minutes ça a l'air très peu comparé aux
deux heures de départ alors qu'en fait
c'est énorme 25 minutes on fait des
parties en cinq minutes des parties
entières
oui donc en 25 minutes si kasparov se
retrouvent gagnant il gagne il n'y a
aucun bluff
- c'est vrai quand on descend en dessous
d'une minute si kasparov et gagnant et
gagne encore donc de toutes façons c'est
tout et rien à la fois c'est un avantage
pour rami qui l'a 15 sud à vence
mais en cas de gafsa ne sauvera pas
simplement s'il ya des problèmes il va
trouver les solutions
alors qu'avec une minute il ne
trouverait pas donc c'est un petit
leadership on peut dire un petit
leadership autant c1
c'est un petit plus en cas de problème
petit élément davantage un petit élément
davantage alors garry kasparov qui quand
même n'a pas l'air satisfait c'est c'est
vraiment intéressant
ce qui va être le plus intéressant c'est
de voir la troisième partie et de revoir
les mêmes joueurs je voulais même coup
avec une nouveauté cette fois ci peut
être du côté kasparov un ami va changer
quatre profs je ne pense pas qu'il
changera puisque c'est vraiment trop
inconstant cette ouverture
les deux joueurs sont là très actif
kasparov tête entre les mains et
chroniques qui s'est avancé sur
l'échiquier on a vu sa chronique qui
tient tête à kasparov l'aïd et en
abandon il faut changer kasparov il sert
à ça c'est une attitude typique stéphane
il ya trop d'armes
c'est l'attitude typique du joueur qui a
décidé de saisir sa chance
oui mais pas recroiser pas les bras
croisés il est comme ça avance et enfin
comme ça il est bien avancé sur
l'échiquier les points derrière l'asie
est en train de se dire il al'air mou
comme ça mais ça va très très vite dans
sa tête ouais ça va ce même envie et il
est probablement en train de se dire la
cites kasparov et une ou deux
imprécisions petites imprécisions
il commence à être mal autant je vais me
le bouffer je vais me le payer
enfin je ne sais pas saisi des trucs
comme ça qu'en dit puisqu'il a l'air
quand très pacifique alors la question
c'est sylvain jouant f2f 4 alors quand
tu auras comme les pions h4 autour de
l'art y est comme le pion h4 contrôle
bien la casse g3 se plie en quatre
finales un peu devenir faible
abbas f24 je pense que c'est une faute
positionnelle puisqu'après donc c'est ce
qu'on a mentionné ici f4 caballos est
maintenant les couloirs sont faciles à
trouver cgeci ses cavaliers f5 et les ja
la casse g3 donc on sera obligé
d'échangés et cavaliers et sa kasparov
ne veux pas parce qu'elles échangent des
cavaliers ça libère des pièces noires
qui n'ont pas beaucoup d espace c'est le
problème des noirs actuelle issa
l'espace donc si on échange des pièces
ça suffira ça libère des cases
ça libère des cases donc à mon avis avec
4 est une faute positionnelle et je vois
mal kasparov faire une faute
positionnelle retour donc à cette
position donc qu'est ce qu'ils ont
actuellement sur l'échiquier et de f4 on
enlève la flèche qu'est ce qui va bien
pouvoir faire peut-être tour d2 alors
tenté douala l'un des deux ça sert à
rien si si ça sert non c'est peut-être
l'un certaines variantes pour éviter
fous ces deux justement autour des 2,5
ou prophylactiques et ça voudrait dire
que kasparov ne sait plus quoi faire
oui c'est un aveu de faiblesse c'est
peut-être un aveu de faiblesse et il
kasparov t'as pas envie peut-être
kramnik aussi un homme plein c'est de
jouer tour huit tours 8 pour pilonner le
pion aux scènes qui finalement est joué
d'après fous ces mythes et puis jouer il
faut c'est vite voilà ça attaque le pion
aux think we seat a créé le bureau 5
avec les deux tours le ca la vallée
chessy ça provoquerait kasparov a joué
4 pour ensuite jouer le plan qu'on a
mentionné éventuellement dans tout à
fait là j'ai l'impression de chronique
est en train de dominer kasparov
ça c'est quand même beau c'est possible
c'est possible que krasniqi réussi à
adapter peut-être kramnik à au moins
égaliser la position s'assemble ce n'est
pas du tout confirmé par l'enisa s'est
pas confirmée par ordinateur qui saigne
encore une fois de plus qui montre une
fois de plus ses limites qui montre ses
limites ou qui en tout cas estime que
peut-être il faillit sais pas quoi en
fait parce qu'il donne quand il donne
comme ça il n'y va lui aussi
l'évaluation de son ordinateur donne un
petit avantage blanc de 0,24 mais ça
veut rien dire parce que leur 0,4 ça
veut dire 41% d'un pion oui donc c'est
rien du tout c'est énorme
1 dominique en plus c'est énorme sachant
qu'un point de plus gagne la partie
enfin l'ordinateur les vaches de son
ordinateur est totalement non non
fiables et puis en plus gagnent pas
toujours la partie puisqu'on peut le
plus peut être un sacrifice de pian
d'accord non mais en plus sans
compensation ça va voilà on a des
références pour ça on a tous les toutes
les parties kasparov karpov
ils ont joué à peu près 120 et si on
regarde bien c'est parti un peu à la
loupe on voit qu'à chaque fois que j'ai
eu en plus ça a été transformé en finale
un peu plus à ce niveau là de la
boucherie c'est mortel c'est mortel donc
non 20 il ya eu des casses peut
qu'asseoir va gagner des parties en
sacrifiant des pions aussi même comme
karpov
il y avait là c'est pas du tout de même
état d'esprit on possède cacher des
pièces on a une pièce de moins mais on
est gagnant sa série
alors voilà la cdca sparrow va passer
sous les 20 minutes il va et donc des
routes on aura les seconds ah oui il
faut rester sur la pendule ça va être ça
va être marrant de voir ça la pendule le
kasparov et à gauche et clignote
ça va être fantastique est vraiment
horreur un décompte avec des seconds on
va avoir des secondes qui vont
s'afficher toute cette technologie qui
vous permet de voir aussi bien que sur
votre montre des seconds
c'est quand même superbe donc non on
peut on peut rester sur ce plan
bon c'est longtemps c'est quand même
intéressant non mais en tout cas c'est
pas la faille et vi neuf minutes 56 500
design c'est pire cinq ans dormaient à
bord pour l'eau de ville alalalala rayé
kasparov et sur orbite
on va mettre un vab être un compteur on
va réactualiser le compteur de la tour
eiffel et oui en mettant le signal de la
pendule de kasparov exactement là il
faut kasparov et dans la position de la
navette spatiale challenger avant le
départ oui à vous avouer houston
rappelons que challenger a explosé en
vol
donc ici annoncé très chaud dans l'es9
castrol ne trouvent plus de solution
mais c'est havas la chronique à un signe
de fraude les sages peut-être qu'il est
fatigué comme une grosse tâche des yeux
de crâne
non mais il faut pas il faut pas se
laisser il faut pas se laisser aller à
dire ce genre de choses puisque
chronique est évidemment en forme il a
calqué son biorythme sur les horaires
des partis c'est sûr ça veut dire qu'il
doit avoir trouvé un rythme doit se
lever 5 heures ou 4 heures avant la
parabolica en pente par l'esa et doit
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant il faut
manger quand même temps avant une partie
alors ça ça dépend des personnes s'étant
clairement des personnes c'est un peu
comme pour faire du sport il faut il
faut se caler pour que l'énergie soit
optimale pendant la partie belge eu
personnellement moi j'ai un rythme je
peux vous raconter le lien puisque je le
connais bien avant les parties je me
réveille donc systématiquement quatre
heures avant donc par exemple le
championnat de france on joue à 17
heures je me lève à une heure de l'après
midi oui c'est un exemple c'est un
exemple agréable la petit déjeuner très
rapide mais vraiment très rapide et très
léger c'est juste un thé suivi de
quelques biscottes salaires vidéo comme
ça d enfin bon bref
ensuite du sport il faut aller courir
lanfains moi je vais courir une petite
demi heure quelque chose comme ça je
travaille un petit peu je me repose je
regarde la télé et évidemment je me suis
préparée la veille au soir
donc je me repose selon qu'ils avaient
appris un peu de sport et là j'arrive à
la partie en pleine forme en prenant
quelques cachets avoir la partie j'en
dirai pas plus sur la gamme la
composition secrète cachée et donc ça va
noter à noter que les
un tournoi comme ça comme tu dis c'est
pas pareil puisque on joue tous les
jours alors que là le championnat du
monde c'est tous les deux jours et donc
je vous rappelle qu'à les matches auront
lieu les mardi jeudi samedi et dimanche
donc on démarre ce dimanche sur une
partie mardin partie jeudi une partie
samedi prochain et dimanche prochains et
comme c'est l'hiver vous pourrez donc
rester parler les journée neigeuse et
pluvieuse à regarder ce superbe match le
week end
exactement du week-end kasparov travnik
à la télé voilà kasparov krainik un
match d'exception première partie c'est
la plus importante du match c'est celle
qui va pas la plus importante maison
qu'elle est importante pour la fois pour
l'ambiance du match
oui c'est celle qui va qui va donner
l'état général de tout ce match
évidemment le plus important c'est la
dernière
si les deux joueurs il va cet ennemi
partout c'est la partie la plus
importante c'est la partie clé oui là
c'est la partie prenante viennent de
jeter un oeil sur la pendule kasparov en
saillie stress il commet 6ème minute 17
minutes et il faut qu'ils jouent ça va
être chaud et ça va être je le vois il
va se passer des choses c'est sûr qu'il
va se passer des choses
ça va aller très reste 19 coups à jouer
c'est géré besoin à peine joué le moitié
des coupes nécessaires pour avant le
contrôle du temps et kasparov il reste
17 minutes 17 minutes ça fait moins 10
minutes par coup ouais ouais ouais tout
le moins de minutes parcours pour jouer
là il peut réfléchir longtemps mais il
va falloir que moment donné il accélère
oui c'est clair et comme temps d'accès
des rémois ont fait des erreurs
ça dépend ça dépend il ya des
spécialistes de ce genre d'accélération
mais ça dépend si celle-ci cramique
arrive à maintenir la pression
ça va être dur pour kasparov il lui
arrive à lui poser deux trois petits
problèmes mais là il ya un problème
énorme
maintenant la question c'est est-ce que
kasparov en 17 minutes va être capable
de le résoudre
parce que là c'est clair à mon avis bon
pas des pas d'évaluation active mais
enfin je pense que kasparov
ici ni serait satisfait par une ne sera
satisfait par égaliser la partie ah oui
parce qu'il est dans de sales draps on
al'impression parce que la chronique à
un plan très simple c'est très simple
pour kramix est facile à jouer il n'a
plus qu'à sortir ces pièces kasparov ces
pièces sont toutes sorties on voit pas
comment il peut les améliorer
ob et d'ailleurs qu'est ce qu'il a fait
depuis tout à l'heure en finalement il a
bougé deux pions h3 ya 4 1 en quoi
indique où est le reste c'est des coups
de cavaliers donc validé en sait trop à
f3 il a réussi à les bouger en e3 et
détroit voilà ce qu'il a fait une sorte
de
techniquement il a fait une prouesse
technique il a bougé ces calories mais
bon les à centraliser walid a centralisé
c'est pas mal mais bon c'est leïla il
est devant remplacer ce qu'ils louaient
ce qui prouve que comme il n'y a pas eu
de mouvement de pions majeurs qu'il n'y
a pas vraiment de plan ouais on te croit
que kramnik a bien réussi à le contrer
alors j'ai fait ce que de travnik lui
peut arriver à à mettre la pression
alors on peut imaginer un pull ample au
crâne moi j'ai envie de voir donc là on
va passer sur l'échiquier de démence tu
parlais de cavaliers de sept mois je
viens de plein vent pour cramique tu me
la serbie de jouer tours 8
oui cavaliers de cette cavale et c6 g6
et fou g7 et le oui non et non mais
attention les cinq cantons seront
stéphane puisque avec lequel j'ai six
bougies et cagliari 4 donc il faut pas
enlever ce qu'est jécistes normes et des
plans pour chroniques on en a trouvé
plein on sait ce qu'on veut quand même
il va jouer tours 8 il va jouer tous ces
huit peut-être ces visites il va
attaquer le pion aux cinq des plans pour
kasparov ouais mais il m'a trouvé c'est
ça qu'il faut retrouver ça me fout donc
là je vais je vais aller voir l'ambiance
de la salle
oui voir comment se comporte un peu tout
le monde dans cette salle je vais aller
voir recueillir des commentaires
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de grands
maîtres qui sont là au bar tu peux
incarner un autre espérant peut-être tu
peux lui demander
je vais aller dans la loge de kasparov
et je reviendrai avec des informations
exceptionnel d'accord dans quelle loi va
voir ça tout de suite alors il ya lancé
très chaud on peut avoir des ont peu à
voir est ce qu'on peut revenir sur un
valoir une plainte kasparov en train de
réfléchir au delà c'est chaud quatorze
minutes 14 minutes pour kasparov
peut-être en plan large pour voir
chronique un plan large de la série b
chronique est pas la chronique est pas
là et laisse kasparov à ces problèmes il
faut le voir un emploi il est vraiment
et il a l'air il a l'air d'être embêté
il a l'air d'être très embêté le pauvre
petit kasparov 14 minutes 14 minutes
pour jouer dix neuf coups mais s'ils
continuent comme ça il va être dans de
trés trés mots sales draps
et ça a pas l'air de s'arranger
alors en plus l'avantagé qu'a cramique
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut qu'ils
fassent cramique même s'il trouve pas de
plan clair pour gagner il faut pas
question il faut pas échanger les pièces
faut essayer de garder un maximum de
pièces parce que plus votre pièce plus
si compliqué et comme kasparov a plus
beaucoup de temps ces idées ces petits
bouts de faire des erreurs
alors si on simplifie évidemment si on
échange des plesses ça devient de plus
en plus facile donc tout ça fait partie
de la gestion du temps que doivent avoir
les joueurs pour donc optimiser leurs
chances très très important le temps aux
échecs
c'est même fondamental de savoir gérer
son temps et de savants gérer le temps
de la partie ça il a joué il a joué sous
ses trois il a joué sous ses trois alors
ça c'est un coup il a pas l'air content
il a pas l'air quoi il faut faire un
pain sur kasparov il est pas content du
tout il est pas content de sa position
kasparov
après fou c3 c'est un coude attentes
visiblement il est pas content de sa
position c'est un coût qui n'améliore
pas sa position
on va pas trop ce qu'il veut faire avec
se fout de toute façon il tape il
n'était pas plus mal en baie de canche
et 3 avait peut-être il attend de voir
maintenant ce que cramique va faire
c'est un aveu d'impuissance
c'est un aveu d'impuissance de kasparov
qui en plaçant ce fois ces trois ne
provoque aucune
aucun changement dans la position donc
c'est un coude attente il veut voir ce
que kramnik propose la chronique il a il
a au moins le coutour 8 à sa disposition
il faut que la torah 8
la tour qui à côté du roi en haut à
gauche b viennent sur la case 1,8 pour
faire pression au centre après il peut
bouger sont fous ces six pour laisser la
tour 8 taper sur le pion 5
par contre on voit mal comment kravitz
peut augmenter la pression après
derrière son champion
il faut aussi que cramique et des idées
il va sûrement trouver comment trouver
alors le problème aussi pour kramnik
c'est de pas laisser faire trop les
choses parce que s'il est trop passer de
coûts sans rien faire et kasparov attend
d'abord il peut y avoir répétition de
position dans ce cas là c'est parti nul
et surtout que ce temps on se rapproche
du 40e coup faut rappeler qu'on est au
22e cook et kasparov il leur reste à peu
près 14 minutes donc il faut lui mettre
la pression pour que la vente âge autant
de chroniques soit deviennent
significatifs donc il faut pas que
cramique resterait pas les bras croisés
l'intérêt de kasparov s'est il sait ce
qu'il a très bien fait dans cette
position il n'a pas d'idée il fait il
n'a pas d'idée il ya même peut-être pas
d'idées à trouver il n'y a pas de plan
possible
donc il a joué un coup d'attentes son
but c'est d'essayer de maintenir le
statu quo au maximum pour athènes le 40e
coûts et retrouver un peu de temps de
réflexion puisque on rajoute une heure
la chronique à jouer il a sûrement joué
le coup tours 8
d'après ce que j'ai vu oui exactement
c'est ce qu'on avait prévu donc tour 1,8
la tour est excellemment placé sur la
colonne mais c'est des coups qu'on avait
prévu la main donc la chronique suit le
plan qu'on avait trop prévu par contre
kasparov a joué encore une fois il
ajoute tour d2 il semblerait que
kasparov et jouer tour d2 voilà coude
attente encore une fois parce qu'on voit
pas trop sinon à quoi peut servir ce
coup
tours d2 effectivement il faut que les
noirs trouve quelque chose ou d'attendre
kasparov kramnik met la pression et
kasparov arrive à tenir lui aussi il n'a
pas eu finalement il n'y a pas de
grosses faiblesses non plus il tient la
position l'avantagent de chroniques
réside principalement dans la pente du
le trouve un plan chroniques ont
maintenant la sortie toutes ces pièces
on peut estimer que toute situation
sortie faut aussi ce qu'avait laissé six
taureaux huit tours h5 problème s'il
faut ensuite où le mettre le problème
c'est comme si on bouge de cavaliers
sicilia le coup cavaliers 4 de kasparov
qui atteint 14 5 qui peut s'échanger à
aussi ce donc là c'est pas c'est pas
simple mais beaucoup de coups de jouer
voyez que là ça s'est accéléré
kasparov a joué des coûts beaucoup plus
rapide à cette chronique j'ai joué à une
passion qui ramène le roi si je me
trompe pas les vues ramener l'euro on va
le voir tout de suite sur l'échiquier
way he was c8 effectivement roi c8
cramique à ramener le roi sur la case c8
donc une suite de coups et loi qui nous
rejoint une suite de coups là ils ont
joué beaucoup de coups kasparov a à
jouer des coudes attentes sont
semble-t-il puisqu'il a joué sous ses
trois tours d2 les chroniques a
effectivement activer sa tour l'âge ou
1,8 et maintenant il remet son roi sur
la case c8 peut-être pour jouer au foot
17 est fou c'est 6
c'est peut-être une petite seconde là je
reprends je reprends mes marques
donc pas de pas de nouvelles dans cette
salle à londres pour l'instant la
nouvelle mise à park
que nous sommes très très nombreux sur
le net à regarder cette partie on est de
plus en plus nombreux sans le team norme
de connexion grandit grandit grandit
donc alors roi c'est 8
oui c'est énorme
donc semble-t-il des chiffres qui me
sont lancés en l'air assez gros c'est
conséquent et les les serveurs de canal
web alors je crois que les techniciens
se sont contents af447
c'est l'affaiblissement que tout le
monde attendait f4 alors f4 c'est c'est
chaud non mais c'est clairement
l'affaiblissement puisque maintenant
voilà on l'avait déjà pointé tout à
l'heure la casse g3 est faible chronique
va évidemment jouer cavalier cette suite
4 5
ça c'est une quasi certitude mais non ce
qui m'étonne c'est que caster fait jouer
4 ça veut dire qu'il a dû voir quelque
chose sur qui avait dit aux élèves et ça
on ne sait pas encore quoi mais il ya
certes sans doute une pointe qui nous a
peut-être échappé alors j'ai beau
chercher je n'en vois pas donc de toutes
façons
supposons skis pas voir l'échiquier de
démonstration de l'avoir cavaliers
hausse est ce qui peut avoir craqué
aussi le coup cavaliers recettes
il semble extrêmement logique car c'est
une supposition est toujours assez
l'échiquier démonstration donc vous fiez
pas c'est échiquier pour la partie
réelle toujours méfiez vous parce que
l'on fait souvent des variantes donc là
c'est une variante après f4 de kasparov
on propose pour kramnik cavalier e set
avec l'idée que f4 menace de pousser de
pousser à f5 et que lecavalier ossètes
contrôle bien la case f5 et va
éventuellement rebondir sur cette case
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a joué il a déjoué
claudio set je vois pas ce qu'il a pu
jouer d'autres on va le voir way rally à
7 bravo quand même là c'est beau parce
que pour une fois on a à peu près trouvé
plomb sur 46 et là il est paré à bondir
à bouygues gros plan sur le sport ou la
la vallée des merveilles où il vient
retirer le cavalier replié un cavalier
qu'avignon f2 alors qu'est ce qu'il a vu
ça y est ça s'accélère ça devient très
très chaud il veut venir e4
c'est très probable finale elle a
profité que cavaliers sont partis d'eux
g6 puisqu'avant ce cavalier protéger f4
voilà tout à fait en fait c'est ça c'est
ça c'est le plan de kasparov
il veut aller sur la 4g cinq là alors là
je pense que cramique va prendre son
temps là parce que cavalli autant qu'ils
veulent il de cet été forcé à nom qui
était jouée vite
là on va pouvoir faire un bilan
d'ailleurs voilà vous le voyez sur son
dossier se mettre un peu en arrière il
veut réfléchir à quoi
kasparov veut jouer qui a eu lieu quatre
écoliers g5 pour déstabiliser ce fou en
russie de quel plan dispose le devenir
chronique il a le coup cavaliers 5 et le
premier qu'on va envisager puisqu'on
l'avait signalé déjà gagné cinq
éoliennes 5 c'est pas mal du tout donc
sur ko 9,5 alors deux possibilités pour
caspar soit qui a aidé 5 soit échange
des cavaliers je pense pas que kasparov
et envie d'échanger je pense plutôt
qu'ils ont envie de jouer qu'ils avaient
des cinq as il peut jouer qui est des
cinq en fait ouais mais sa menace
quoique avec des cinq semaines africains
non seulement nasri recevoir ces 10 août
avec des 5 et après bon métier des 5e
perd tout de suite suite qu'elles
étaient cinq ont expliqué des saints qui
ça perdrait tout de suite à cause de ses
six je pense si je n'ai pas dit de
bellevue rejet d'une bavure
effectivement puisque après qu'elle
prend b6 si droite avec le cavalier le
pion à 500 prises donc oui mais c'est
pas une bonne idée donc là on peut jouer
roy bessette pour menacer de jouer ces
six gagne le cavalier moment de revenir
on va revenir calmement là tout de suite
voilà qu'avec deux kaliev 2 alors non je
pense que qu'il n'y ait dans lequel
petit des deux chronos mais il faut
aussi que ce que je dis c'est à leur bon
si kramnik vous essayer de gagner cette
partie
ou en tout cas profiter au maximum de la
perte de temps à 15 par an faut pas
qu'ils jouent des coups anodins
s'ils jouent des conneries en 1970 du
tout anodin ces panneaux des noms mais
justement alors mais il faut pas qu'ils
jouent des kwh anodin parce que s'ils
jouent des coûts trop trop facile entre
guillemets à dix on a joué ça ensemble
sans faire de menaces etc
kasparov peut tranquillement atteindre
le 40e coup il a pas l'air content
kasparov là il est dans une position il
n'y a pas l'air content alors là voilà
ça ça veut dire quelque chose cette tête
là c'est à dire que c'était voilà c'est
ça ça veut dire maintenant c'est trop
facile j'ai tout compris
oui tout est forcé c'est nul que ce
matin pour volx nuls qu'est ce que tu
attends on fait nul le thouet tube tu es
relayé quoi tu me fais chier en fait
j'ai envie de jouer et ça c'est évident
mais devrait comprendre alors qu'il n'a
que 11 minutes 38 secondes
oui ça c'est du c'est vraiment du grand
bluff de garry kasparov il faut qu'il
trouve quelque chose quand les digues et
là c'est très clair que kramnik en 34
minutes
j'ai ça les moyens j'ai sauvé et coupa
joue j'essaie maintenant on va chez 5
ans possible s'affaiblit à 4,6 au public
beaucoup trop là kadhafistes c'est vrai
les oeillades de garry kasparov
il faut pas rater ça là c'est vraiment
il faudrait se confondent et noté le
temps là deux sets de 7 de ce moment là
c'est vraiment les mimiques
c'est pour notre concours top position
aulas aaa à aa il aurait vu quelque
chose à où il est le front plissé
il est pas content anglais garry
kasparov qui est pas quand ou là c'est
vraiment une très très bonne nage a les
oreilles les oeillades qui l'envoie
sacré gary chronique
annie qui se laisse pas impressionner
alors je ne sais pas si c'est la
différence de cadres mais en tout cas et
kasparov a l'air plus gros casse parfait
l'argon maintenant c'est une petite
chaise c'est parce qu'il a une petite
charlotte sarhani cas une grande chaise
et donc quand tu as l'impression qu'ils
dépassent le dossier ce qui devrait
d'ailleurs pas qu'une impression mais
c'est parce que je faisais plus petit
est tout à fait ça doit être ça quand
même qui est plus bas pour gagner plus
bas nos photos nyokas prof est sans
doute plus bon enfant peu importe
revenons à la position
position parce que c'est extrêmement
critique donc position revenir
l'échiquier démonstration dans quelques
instants nous y voilà kelly f2 donc là
je pense que krasniqi en train
d'envisager qu'un média cinq autres
possibilités qu on pourrait mentionner
pour chronique je ne vois pas ce que ça
peut l'être c'est parce que si la vague
il veut avoir quelque chose je sais pas
j'ai six mois j'ai six s'affaiblit
lacazette 6 alors ça affaiblit la classe
des femmes
tu as une fâcheuse tendance à vouloir
bouger ton plongez donc nous allons
montrer à tous les internautes
ouais mais peut-être fou j'ai c'est
pourquoi ce n'est pas bon et bien parce
qu'après cabello quatre menaces kalyev 6
la whey fourchette attaque la tour 8es
la tourache 5
mais c'est pas bon et surtout g5 et bien
évidemment ici on se fait on se fait pas
de bien voilà c'est le calaisien g5
datacloud f7 à l'option obsèques le faut
aussi l'autre cavani va venir en d5 est
peut-être arrivé à 9,6 bref c'est la
cata il ya des trous quoi donc
maintenant s'il était interdit de
proposer un coup avec le pion g voilà
donc là il faut jouer j'ai cinq noms ici
qu'à sport vaugeois qui est de 4,4 g
nique très concentré non là je pense
qu'il est en train de chercher
clairement à saisir sa chance des moyens
de saisir sa chance
alors voyons plus en profondeur qui a eu
lieu sans que je pense que c'est
vraiment le coup logique ici si cramique
dire autre chose ça sera une surprise
mais bon on aime les surprises
il pourrait jouer autour des 8 envisage
en cavale et prend km autour des 8
peut-être non c'était une autre
possibilité aux cayes prend cavaliers
com quelle est la reprise de logique
dans cette position du fou de la tour
bah ouais du fou et c'est peut-être pour
ça que je veux qu'à spa en faire le tour
des deux si on prend du fou ont menacé
de tout à fait alors là il faut bien
mentionné que kasparov a joué très
prophylactique lui aussi sur fou prend
la caf c2 n'est plus possible à la fin
des horaires taquiner les pions blancs
et ça aurait été embêtant
non donc ici à mon humeur prendre la
tour entre prendre ma tour peut-être en
attaque le pion à flers bourg est
indélogeable jamais cavalier e 4 annonce
peut-être stéphane ignorer cavaliers
g4tv g4 peut-être avec qui des carriers
ou trois c'est ça et je voulais essayer
de
entre 3 et 3,5 peut-être possible
peut-être que devrait également dans
cette position qu'avait dit aux quatre
pour venir angers 5
ça c'est également une possibilité
qu'est ce qui se passe il ce qu'il
aurait du même coup j'ai vu kasparov en
traîne noter sa partie j'ai pas vu
j'étais sur les charentes démonstrative
allons vérifier les chiffres réels
oui voilà non et non non rien n'a été
jouée cramique n'apaisera la tête de
kasparov là il faut absolument le voir
là à la tête de la la aulas c'est une
bête de scène
une bête de cirque ah oui je ne sais
plus comment dire mais il est quand même
champion du monde d'échecs le kasparov
chaud rappelons qu'à sport fait comme un
spécialiste des exhibitions puisqu'il a
joué un match entre stig danse ting
tings tings et son groupe et donc pas
stig englishman in new york à 10 m
synchro est joué par chronique
ouais c'est vrai il ya lyon ça l'a vu
elle voir une nulle possible il a
peut-être proposer nul oh non non non
les fans s'ils ont fait nul cabinet
partie de match nul voilà donc la plan
large là pour voir les joueurs voilà
respect de kram nique
granic respecte garry kasparov ils font
nul donc c'est une petite victoire de
crabes nico aujourd'hui finalement comme
l' arbitre qui vient et oui donc les
joueurs ont fait nul donc non en fait
une petite victoire pour chronique en
tout cas victoire dans l'ouverture ça
c'est clair on peut le dire autre chose
très important les deux joueurs sont
entrés dans le match de façon tranquille
ouais je dirais que kasparov et à
peut-être fait un meilleur début de
match la mesure où il a plus réfléchi
plus commencé à tenter sa chance
alors on vous rappelle qu' il ya la
conférence de presse normalement entre
les joueurs qui va avoir lieu dans un
quart d'heure à peu près dix minutes un
quart d'heure normalement on leur
transmet donc on va essayer de récupérer
le son est évidemment de cette interview
de 7,1
conférence de presse avec les images ou
les joueurs vont expliquer un petit peu
dans cette partie donc ça va être entre
directes d'ici dix minutes un quart
d'heure et ensuite il y aura une
émission en résumé en anglais et en
français et en france et donc deux
résumés en résumé de résumer de m suivez
normalement dès demain matin
voilà voilà donc l'antenne et on vous
dit rendez vous à tout à l'heure
voilà enfin l'antenne on va peut-être
laissé quelques images
puis on va on va peut-être couper tous
les rangs
rugby amine fame on veut match
pourquoi
au moment des taux très bas
space to work
quoi être dégoûté au cours de l'été au
but
une preuve d'une problèmes profonds
remords conditions de bottines généraux
même satisfaite
higgins était fort mal et aux 565 et few
good eprint madoff cos am chose
nous veillerons